not long to go until we find out that
final decision on the high-speed rail
link now the Chief Inspector of OFT's
fed in Mendes filming gave a speech
recently where she tried to tackle what
she calls the undiscussables in
education so to discuss those
undiscussables I'm delighted to say that
a monster when joins us now in the
studio thank you very much being on the
program this morning so what do you mean
when you talk about the undiscussables
in education we look right across all
the services that affect children with
education and social care and want
something that's become really clear to
me over the the three years I've been
doing this job is how often problems
come about because we don't talk about
things that need talking about and it's
been true in schools it's it's true it's
true true in social care we do joint
inspections if I think that we're
publishing a report tomorrow looking at
child sexual abuse in the family and
here we found so much evidence that that
things are being shut down by people not
wanting to talk about the difficult
stuff we'll talk about that a report
specifically later in the interview as
well and so when we're talking about the
things that people are afraid to discuss
it does feel that sometimes this is
issues of culture issues of faith and
some of the investigations that you've
done
you speak about finding discrimination
against girls in particular in schools
and I think you give two examples of a
school in Birmingham and a Jewish school
in London what kind of things you find
in well we found so clip in in in a
skinner school in Birmingham we found
some very very rigid segregation that
meant that boys were always put ahead of
girls for everything children literally
didn't see each other we found but I'm
if I'm some books in the library that
was saying men can beat their wives
provided they don't leave their mark and
that women aren't entitled to refuse sex
to their husbands and this is the al-haj
rah Islamic school in Birmingham yes
this is this is a community school it's
a it's a state-funded community school
theoretically for all children so it's
it's a real problem because you talk
about this and people cover it briefly
and then it's as though it had never
happened people are very very reluctant
to talk about the very difficult issues
that some of these cases raised you
speak like the Jewish school as well
where some books will redact
including the reign of Queen Elizabeth
the first yes that was that was another
school where girls education was was
being very restricted and not just on
the kinds of topics that we know are
sensitive for some people around even
evolution and reproduction but I think
think things as as startling as that as
the history of the reign of Queen
Elizabeth the girls weren't allowed to
know about that so there's a there's a
slide to just shutting down what
children are allowed to know how can we
make sure that everybody's prepared for
adult life
if we let schools have narrow and narrow
what they do how arthritis is it's it's
a small minority of schools but but the
point is because of our sensitivities
about religion about culture about
ethnicity and we're very very reluctant
to say we've got some really tough
issues here where questions of religion
questions of other kinds of rights and
the different rights bump into each
other how do we help resolve that how do
we get to something that does recognize
that the end of the day this is about
putting children first and making sure
that they grow up to become become fully
British citizens with all that that
we'll all the rights and
responsibilities and privileges that
that entails I mean do you think that
some people are afraid of talking openly
I guess about as you say when religious
believes when faiths when personal and
cultural faiths come into conflict with
for example the rights of girls or gay
people do our politicians need to be a
bit braver oh there's no question that
we're afraid I'm all the dreadful
dreadful grooming gang stories all those
many many convictions and for child
sexual exploitation in practically every
putt every part of the country that is
shown so vividly what happens when we
censor ourselves when we don't allow
ourselves to acknowledge that there may
be a particular dimension to a problem
so it's it does two things one is it
leaves those particular children exposed
for far too long to the particular home
but also it means we don't have the
right conversation about what the things
are that we need to tackle and how to
address them as as early as we possibly
can and yes sometimes sometimes like
very much affects girls but it cuts
across the board because we've got all
these different rights that can bump
into each other so we desperately need a
lot of these situations everybody to be
a bit bright braver and calling thing
by their name talking about what's there
I mean I guess another right that we're
talking about is gain lesbian rights as
well and you think of course of those
protests outside that school in
Birmingham about the teaching of
relationship education family education
do you think the schools are supported
enough in those cases I know that the
schools absolutely have felt unsupported
and we we leave the decisions to schools
about what to teach and when there is
there is some government guidance but
it's it's pretty high level there's an
in practice and immense responsibility
on the heads even of tighly primary
schools to take on something that is
really difficult and contentious in many
communities you say that schools full-on
supporter who should be supporting them
well the local authorities for Community
Schools the Maps local politicians
councilors MPs national politicians we
should recognize that there is a real
difficulty a real problem here that that
remarkably few people are willing to
pick up and talk about and we've been
talking about faith and and clearly the
majority of faith schools are doing a
great job men excellent job I'm sure
absolutely however there is a new wave
of state-funded voluntary aided faith
schools coming in and initially
announced by Theresa May do you think we
need to look at the number of faith
schools in the UK is no such general
argument that the off-state
Ofsted has about about faith schools
beyond that many of them do a fantastic
job if we look in the state sector
overall I think judgments for our faith
schools are at least as good if not if
not slightly better than also all
schools in the independent sector we see
a very different picture and we see us
of concerning picture among that that
relatively small group of schools but
it's what should be done about that then
the first step is acknowledging the
dimensions of the problem and saying we
do have we do now have a kind of
divergence among parent group parent
groups in different cultures different
backgrounds and that makes what we could
what we could have assumed everybody
would have accepted in a school 50 years
ago is no longer by default acceptable
to my
to nine parents out of 100 so we start
from further back in having to talk
about things in having to educate
parents in really having to rethink
models of Education to make sure that we
can take take take things forward and
build and unify people rather than
reinforcing divisions at the beginning
of the interview you mentioned the
report you have coming out on sex abuse
again a nun discussable topic for many
and it had some pretty worrying findings
what exactly does it show it shows a
number of things it shows first of all
that a lot of children are getting left
in the lurch for months if not years
through a very very long long drawn-out
investigations and this is when reports
are made about potential sex abuse yes
in in the home my child is disclosed
something that's happened to them at
home which of itself often takes a long
while for a child to be able to do and
then sometimes it can be weeks even
before the person is alleged to have
done whatever it is is even interviewed
it can take a year for investigations to
be completed in cases to come to court
and often during that time all the
attention is on the person being
investigated there's almost no attention
to the child and often arrest isn't used
bet there aren't bail conditions or
restrictions on the individual so the
child may be subject to the same abuse
throughout the investigation and then
even when people are convicted there's
often so very weak management of
offenders who come out of prison again
restrictions may not be set may not be
effective and there's a lot of weight
put on women to manage contact sometimes
with with partners or former partners
which puts a very heavy burden on them
especially when they might have been
abused themselves it's really concerning
and findings and there's been a lack of
join up as well for the problems that
children themselves may develop because
we find it so hard to talk about this me
nor mr. boo about sex between people who
are related and here we've got things
that are essentially manifestations of
incestuous incestuous relationships and
often child rape we find it so so hard
to talk about these things and call them
what they are and why do you think these
issues are arising is it partly funding
is it because
the agencies didn't have the money to do
the investigations in a timely fashion
or as you say is it more of a cultural
problem where we're scared to talk about
it I think in this one we've got
something that is very deep-seated in
probably in every culture around the
world that always has been a terrific
taboo around incest which makes it hard
to talk about these things nobody likes
to think of bad things like this
happening to to children in their own
home and yet the evidence says that
throughout history across the world
these things always have and always will
arise so it's a it's about being ready
ready to teach people to explain to
communicate that these things can happen
and joining up the services this this
lack of connection is something that
we've picked up in a number of the joint
inspections that we've done on on
dealing with domestic abuse child sexual
exploitation over and over again we see
this pattern of the different services
that are meant to help and protect
children finding it hard to talk to each
other hard to share information harm to
create this kind of concerted prompt
action and I just want to finish by
talking be about off stairs because
Ofsted is under pressure and teachers of
course often talk about the pressure
that Ofsted puts them under at the last
election Labour proposed abolishing
Ofsted entirely this is what the shadow
education secretary Angela Rayne has
said she said I believe Ofsted measures
poverty it measures deprivation it
doesn't measure excellence its Ofsted
biased against schools with more
deprived intakes it absolutely isn't
what we've said over and over again we
know that it's often harder running
schools in disadvantaged areas and yet
we're reporting to parents on what their
children are getting we could never say
that this education is is is good enough
for a child in Grimsby but it's not good
enough wouldn't be good enough for a
child in Notting Hill we have to keep
that same standard and I think if you
talk to parents everywhere they have the
same kinds of expectations for their
children no parent would say because
because we live here it's it's okay that
we should get a lesser standard of
Education so yes there are enormous
challenges in trying to make sure that
the system really can deliver the same
quality of education everywhere
but it's also right that the independent
Inspectorate should look at it and see
say what our children actually getting
talking about the importance of
inspections and there was a policy
previously where if a school had been
deemed outstanding then it didn't have
to go through these kind of automatic
timely inspection some schools weren't
reinstated for a decade that's now
changed was that mistake
it hasn't changed yet but but a very
welcome consultation has been published
on what was it a mistake to not have
these regular inspections outstanding
school our view is that it was it was a
mistake and we are delighted that
finally this this Education Secretary's
decided to do something about it because
it's left a lot of schools simply not
looked at and everybody knows that
schools that schools schools are not
honest or one-way conveyor schools can
get worse as well as better and of
course there's also much more to schools
than just the top-line reported results
so so leaving schools for 10-12 even 12
years even even longer um in my view has
been a really retrograde approach thank
you so much for being on the program and
talking so frankly about some of those
and difficult topics much appreciated
thank you